- [Coss] Yo BuzzFeed,
my name is Coss Marte
and my personal transformation happened
in a nine by six prison cell.
(dramatic music)
I was raised in a heavily
drug infested community
in the lower east side
section of Manhattan.
People would ask me
"what do you want to be
"when you grow up?"
I'd tell em that I wanted to be rich
and the first opportunity I got
was through the world of drugs.
I started smoking at the age of 11
and at the age of 13 I made my first sale.
This led me to the corner
on Broom and Elder street,
where I began to pitch all the drugs
with the local guys who
respected my hustle.
By the age of 19, I was the leader
of a cocaine distributing
ring in New York City.
I was making over two
million dollars a year.
My first run with NYPD was at
the age of 13, and from then,
I was in and out of jail
for the next few years.
When I was 23, I was
caught by federal agents
and was sentenced to
seven years in prison.
During my incarceration
I was overweight and extremely unhealthy.
The doctors in prison told me
that I could die of a heart
attack within five years.
But with a seven year
sentence in front of me,
I was determined.
I was not going to die in prison.
So I started working out.
I developed a workout routine
using just my body weight
that could be done in a small prison cell.
And, in just six months, I lost 70 pounds.
Then I started training other inmates
and I helped 20 inmates lose
over a thousand pounds combined.
As my release date got closer,
I got into an altercation with an officer
and was placed in solitary confinement.
I was beaten and thrown into a cell.
Alone with my thoughts,
I kept asking myself why.
I wrote a 10 page letter out to my family
explaining what happened
and that I wasn't coming
home any time soon.
And then I realized that I
didn't have a stamp to send it.
After two weeks in solitary,
my sister sent me a letter
and suggested I read
Psalm 91 from the Bible.
I flipped open right to Psalm 91,
and that's when a stamp fell out.
It was the stamp that I needed
to send out my letter with.
I read the whole Bible from cover to cover
and received a sense of peace and calm,
despite my surroundings.
My whole perspective on life changed.
I began to believe that my
purpose was to give back
instead of destroying
the people around me.
When I got out, I realized
that my way of giving back
was through the world of fitness
and that's when I started ConBody.
ConBody is a president style boot camp
that hires formerly
incarcerated individuals
to teach fitness classes
based on the workout I
developed in my cell.
In just two and a half years,
ConBody has gone from workouts in the park
to studios in NYC with 12 employees,
over 7,000 clients and
over 200 classes per week.
My business has been featured
in over 100 international media outlets.
Today I travel the
country visiting prisons,
training inmates in hopes
of creating a pipeline
of trainers for ConBody.
Our mission is to create a
bridge between two communities,
young professionals and formerly
incarcerated individuals.
At ConBody, we view each
other as real human beings
and seek to break down the stereotypes
that formerly incarcerated
individuals face.
Whoever dwells in the
shelter of the most high,
will rest in the shadow of the almighty.
(dramatic music)
Thanks for reading, Coss.